After the Revolutionary War, George Washington
looked forward to a quiet retirement as a
gentleman farmer in Virginia.
But this was not to be as he was repeatedly
called back to serve the needs of the new
nation he helped create.
When he was called to serve as the United
States’ first president in 1789, Washington
said on April 16 of that year, “My love
of retirement is so great, that no earthly
consideration, short of a conviction of duty,
could have prevailed upon me to depart from
my resolution ‘never more to take any share
in transactions of a public nature.”
When his term was up, he was unanimously re-elected,
keeping him away from his home, Mount Vernon,
for another four years.
As war was looming on the horizon in 1798,
Washington accepted command of American forces
once again, although this time around his
position was more ceremonial and advisory,
rather than hands-on, due to his advanced
age.
President Washington and his wife Martha finally
managed to make it to Virginia, where most
of their time was consumed with making the
long-neglected Mount Vernon solvent once more.
The General took an active role in the running
of his plantation, overseeing the work of
the slaves (about 318 at this time working
at Mount Vernon) and other workers, and inspecting
his property.
And he was doing just that on December 12,
1799 in a cold, miserable mixture of snow,
sleet and rain on horseback for several hours.
The following day, Washington didn’t feel
very well, stating he had a sore throat.
But he still rode out during a heavy snowfall
to mark trees for cutting on his property.
He was hoarse upon his return but made light
of it to his wife and secretary.
When offered medicine he shrugged if off saying,
“You know I never take anything for a cold.
Let it go as it came.”
(His wife had recently recovered from a cold,
so presumably he just thought he’d caught
the same.)
By the early morning hours of December 14,
1799, Washington was seriously ill.
His breathing was significantly impaired,
so much so that he could barely speak, but
he would not allow his wife to seek help for
fear the night air would result in a return
of her own sickness.
When their maid came to their room at sunrise,
she was sent to fetch Mr. Albin Rawlins, the
estate overseer, who prepared a mixture of
butter, molasses and vinegar and helped the
General drink it.
The result was the opposite of what they’d
hoped.
Instead of soothing his throat, attempting
to swallow the thick mixture nearly resulted
in him suffocating and sent him into convulsions.
Next came that mainstay of medicine of the
time – bloodletting, of which General Washington
was a big fan.
Mrs. Washington – not so much, so as her
husband was encouraging Rawlins to go for
the gusto, the Missus was telling him to dial
it back.
Rawlins must have been very relieved when
doctors actually began showing up.
Dr. James Craik, Washington’s personal physician
and friend, arrived and, seeing his friend
with an inflamed, swollen throat, bled him
once more.
At the time, it was thought that by removing
blood from the body, it could potentially
take down swelling and reduce inflammation.
Dr. Craik also administered another oral medicine
comprised of vinegar and sage tea, and applied
a poultice to Washington’s neck (and later
elsewhere on his body) containing ground,
dried beetles.
These beetles contained a substance known
as cantharidin, which, when it comes in contact
with human skin, causes blisters to rapidly
form, again trying to balance out the fluids
in Washington’s body to reduce the inflammation
and swelling that was making it difficult
for him to breathe.
None of this worked.
Another physician, Dr. Elisha Dick, arrived
at 3 p.m. and, seeing that Washington could
still barely breathe, it was decided that
they should risk bleeding the General once
more…
The last doctor to come, Dr. Gustavus Brown,
showed up shortly after, and all three agreed
to treat the patient rectally with calomel
and tartar.
(At least they didn’t blow smoke up his
backside, as was another common treatment
when people were suffering from breathing
issues, such as drowning victims.)
After a fourth and final bleeding and after
administering a substance to make Washington
vomit, with no positive affect, not surprisingly,
Washington had had enough.
Having 32 ounces of blood removed over the
course of the day, induced blisters on various
places on his body, and lack of ability to
take in air, his life was slipping away anyway.
He told the three physicians, “I feel myself
going.
I thank you for your attentions but I pray
you take no more troubles about me.
Let me go off quietly.
I cannot last long.”
He had his wife bring him the two wills he
had made, which he read over and had one destroyed.
Among other things, he noted in his will that
all his slaves should be freed upon his wife’s
death and those who were too elderly or sick
to work should continue to be supported by
the estate.
Further, those who were unable to acquire
an education on their own should be provided
with tutors to teach them reading, writing,
and some useful trade with which they could
then support themselves after being freed.
A slave owner since the age of 11, Washington’s
views on slavery had changed radically over
the course of his lifetime, near the end of
his life noting in stark contrast to earlier
attitudes he had held,
The unfortunate condition of the persons,
whose labour in part I employed, has been
the only unavoidable subject of regret.
To make the Adults among them as easy & as
comfortable in their circumstances as their
actual state of ignorance & improvidence would
admit; & to lay a foundation to prepare the
rising generation for a destiny different
from that in which they were born; afforded
some satisfaction to my mind, & could not
I hoped be displeasing to the justice of the
Creator.
He also instructed Tobias Lear to “arrange
and record all my late military letters and
papers.
Arrange my accounts and settle my books, as
you know more about them than any one else,
and let Mr. Rawlins finish recording my other
letters which he has begun.”
That done, he gave instructions on how he
wanted his body handled after his death.
Washington was a taphephobic (irrationally
terrified of being buried alive).
To avoid this, his specific instructions for
his body included “do not let my body be
put into the vault in less than three days
after I am dead.
Do you understand?”
While today, the fear of being buried alive
is quite irrational in most parts of the world-
besides the more obvious ways we’re better
at telling, the widespread practice of embalming
guarantees the person is dead before burial-
in Washington’s time, it wasn’t necessarily
crazy to be afraid of this happening.
For instance, in 1896, T.M.
Montgomery, who was supervising the disinterment
of remains at the Fort Randall Cemetery, reported
that a little over 2% of those bodies exhumed
were definitely victims of being accidentally
buried alive.
In other words, about 2% woke up, tried to
claw their way out, and were unable to do
so.
Given the oxygen supply in a coffin doesn’t
last that long, it is likely the actual percentage
of people buried alive was higher, when you
include the ones who didn’t wake, but were
still technically alive when buried.
As another example, in the 17th century, William
Tebb compiled a list of 219 instances of narrow
escape from premature burial; 149 cases of
actual premature burial; 10 cases in which
bodies were accidentally dissected before
death; and 2 cases in which embalming was
started on the still living.
The reason the rate of being buried alive
was quite high around this time was primarily
due to the high number of people dying of
various diseases like cholera, smallpox, etc.
These people tended to not get a close investigation
to make sure they were really dead, rather
than just unconscious, and they also tended
to be buried quickly to prevent the spread
of whatever disease they were thought to have
died from.
In any event, Washington died at approximately
10 p.m. on Saturday, December 14, 1799 at
the age of 67.
When told that her husband was finally past
his pain, she said, “Is he gone?
‘Tis well.
All is now over.
I shall soon follow him.
I have no more trials to pass through.”
So, beyond the doctors’ well-intentioned-but-more-harmful-than-good
“care,” what is thought to have killed
George Washington?
It’s believed today that President Washington
died of an inflamed epiglottis (the flap near
the base of the tongue that keeps food from
getting into your windpipe).
In extreme cases, swelling of the epiglottis
can block the airway sufficiently to cause
the person to suffocate.
As to what caused the inflammation, this condition
is most often the result of a Haemophilus
influenzae type B or strep infection.
Whatever the underlying cause, the net result
was inability to get sufficient oxygen to
support the body.
The massive blood loss he sustained in such
a short time may have also sent him into hypovolemic
shock, resulting in his heart being unable
to pump sufficient blood throughout the body.
Combined with the lack of oxygen, this very
probably would have resulted in some of his
organs ceasing to function.
Interestingly, when it became apparent that
no safe amount of bloodletting was going to
reduce the swelling enough to allow Washington
to breathe normally, the second doctor, Elisha
Dick, suggested doing a radical new procedure
called a tracheotomy to open the airway to
allow Washington to breathe (something that
likely would have helped tremendously and
may have even saved his life in combination
with ceasing to bleed him anymore), but the
technique was so new (and the patient so illustrious
no doubt) that the other doctors argued against
it and stuck to tried and true medical treatments
like bloodletting, inducing blisters via beetles,
and shoving stuff up people’s bums.